LeBron James five to shoot big he pokes  it away James up and under throws it off  the backboard shuffle and a perfect pass  to himself hey Mike  how about this play by LeBron James  great recognition great awareness  tremendous god-given ability great  awareness tremendous god-given ability  opportunity of the half here  [Music]  [Applause]  goes with the steal James late again  and again Booker having to play straight  up where you threw it off the glass on  perfect to get to Levi  James will get one final opportunity  that happened just mrs. Julius Irving  dr. Jay and Tim Duncan so the box  tickets with the basket that's our  America's diamond season ticket  spotlight well said mr. Ali